today on the Matt Walsh show the left
now says that Mount Rushmore has to go
because it was carved on stolen land
they say but the reality isn't nearly as
simple as that in fact the whole
narrative of white settlers stealing
land from from Indians
isn't quite that simple we'll try to
inject some historical context and
reality into this discussion today also
five headlines including the bloodbath
in our cities over the weekend where is
black lives matter on this they're
nowhere to be found and an education
council meeting in New York descends
into total leftist insanity you have to
hear it and see it to believe it but you
know it raises a question of why would
anyone send their kids to public school
at this point I think there's there's
just no excuse to do that so we'll talk
about that today and so much more all of
that on the way but we start here
the latest monument to come under fire
by the left as I mentioned is one that
they'll probably need more than a chain
and a band of vandals to pull down Mount
Rushmore is according to the media a
symbol of white domination and quote
white supremacy and even worse now it's
the site of a president Trump speech so
that's the that's the ultimate
historical atrocity and so it must be as
a recent New York Times article put it
reconsidered we have to reconsider it
seems a little bit late now to
reconsider it if you ask me AG la la' su
president Julian Bear runner believes
the monument should quote come down but
these are these are giant 60-foot faces
carved into a mountain by the way he
says we have to come down but not via
explosives so because blowing up a
60-foot face carved into the side of a
mountain would bear runner concedes
probably caused more damage than
whatever unspecified damage is caused by
its continued presence in the first
place so what are we gonna do maybe we
put a tarp over it maybe here's a better
idea we could you know those those gag
glasses with the noses and the funny
mustaches we could make really big
versions of those and put them on all
the faces you know because that way it
covers up the white supremacy and it's
funny to look at so that's an idea but
the most interesting part of this
belated Mount Rushmore backlash is the
he did claim that we have to repent of
the monument and somehow remove it
because it was built on stolen land it's
that particular claim I want to focus on
here's your just a quick compilation of
the media saying this over and over
again Donald Trump shows the most
grandiose symbol of US imperialism on
earth so uh sure in a very on brand
star-spangled spectacle the mother of
all photo ops Mount Rushmore and we know
why this president just can't resist
going there President Trump will be at
Mount Rushmore where he'll be standing
in front of a monument of two slave
owners and on land wrestled away from
Native Americans we have to acknowledge
that Mount Rushmore is sitting on Lakota
land the place Donald Trump is going to
on Friday his stolen land senator Tammy
Duckworth who's being considered for Joe
Biden's VP spot has also echoed this
this theme over the weekend she was
asked about it and and she also said
that it's on stolen land I think we
should listen to the everybody I think
we should listen to to the argument
there but remember that the president at
Mount Rushmore was standing on ground
that was stolen from Native Americans
who had actually been given that land
during a treaty and again let's talk
about the greater context of where we
are in our country right now you know
the our historical past we need to talk
about what we're doing now to bring this
country off of the brink of chaos that
it's in okay stolen stolen from quote
Native Americans who acquired it quote
during a treaty she says now there's a
lot in there that I think needs to be
dissected because a lot of it is wrong
and we'll talk about all that in just a
second but before we do I want to tell
you about our friends at helix sleep
they're sponsoring the show today and
you know I if you've ever had the
experience we all I think I've had the
experience of sleeping on a really
horrible mattress you know one that just
is sort of like fighting with your body
the entire night does it seems like a
mattress that doesn't want to be slept
on it seems like and if you have a
mattress like that it can really it can
really do it could do a number on you
because if you're not sleeping well then
your
living well and everything else that's
why you need helix sleep now helix sleep
has a quiz takes just two minutes to
complete I've done it myself and it
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you so if you like mattresses that are
really soft really firm if you sleep on
your side or your back your stomach
however you sleep whatever you like in a
mattress they're gonna specify it to
your unique taste you don't need to take
their word for it either helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress of 2019 and 2020 by GQ and
Wired magazine go to helix sleep comm
slash walls take their two minutes sleep
quiz and they're gonna match you to a
customized mattress that will give the
best sleep of your life I'm telling you
I have one of these mattress as myself
and I can absolutely attest to that
right now helix is offering up to $200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix sleep
comm slash walls that's helix sleep
dot-com slash walls for up to $200 off
your mattress order go there now
so tammy duckworth
as so many leftists tend to do you know
she speaks of Native Americans as if
they're all this this this homogenous
unified group so white settlers stole
the land from Native Americans generally
she says which is kind of like saying
the British stole land from Asians when
they occupied India no you wouldn't say
that because they didn't take it from
Asians they didn't take land from the
Chinese the Vietnamese they took land
from Indians and that's that's what you
would say and the distinction is
important in fact leftist usually would
be the first to tell you that it's
racist to erase or minimize or ignore
these kinds of distinctions to act like
there's no difference between someone
from one Asian country or another or no
difference between one Indian tribe and
another they would usually say that's
racist yet in this case they're doing it
themselves why is that well I think
there's a reason why the we stole the
land crowd it's often sort of hesitant
to get specific on the matter of who
exactly we stole this land from whether
it's the Black Hills and
Dakotah or any other plot of land that
we supposedly stole now the problem I
think is helpfully illustrated by this
PBS article which says the black hills
were appropriated and this is this is a
claim not just by PBS but anytime the
media gets more specific they're gonna
tell you they were is appropriated from
the Lakota Sioux tribe who were
according to PBS quote the original
occupants of the area now that is if you
have any understanding of history at all
that is an absolutely ridiculous claim
it would be like me saying that I was
the first person to ever fly I I
invented human flight when I took a
plane from Baltimore to Charlotte last
March it's in fact that would be less
ridiculous because the Lakota Sioux were
thousands of years removed from being
the first people the original occupants
of the Black Hills there has been a
human presence in the Black Hills since
prehistoric times going back over 10,000
years and from that era until the u.s.
stole it allegedly many groups of people
have fought often quite brutally for
control of that region slightly more
recently the Aerie cara tribe moved in
around the time that Columbus sailed the
ocean blue around you know the late
1400s early 1500s the Cheyenne the Kiowa
the crow other tribes all arrived in
short order to fight for their own share
of this coveted mountain range
finally after hundreds of years of this
the Lakota the alleged original
occupants came in the 18th century and
drove all the other competitors away and
established control of that area now
it's when I say drove away it's worth
noting that for Indian tribes driving
competitors away often meant murder
pillage torture scalping and similar
methods the u.s. did not take the Black
Hills from its original occupants the
original occupants had long
since been exiled or exterminated by
other Native American tribes the u.s.
arrived and was formed and founded
thousands of years too late to take it
from its original occupants it would be
more accurate to say now this is not
ever how it's actually phrased but if
you care about accuracy what you're
gonna say is that the u.s. took the
Black Hills from the most recent tribe
that had taken it from the tribe that
had most recently taken it before then
and so on and so on and so on now this
is not mere pedantry okay this is not
not being pedantic and getting into like
splitting hairs here the point is that
white settlers and pioneers by trying to
claim and conquer new land were not
introducing some new horror to the
continent it wasn't like they were doing
something that these these Indian tribes
were scandalized by because they'd never
heard of anyone doing this before okay
now the Indian tribes were would have
would have been angry about being moved
out of their land but they weren't
scandalized by the concept the way that
we are now because this is exactly what
they were doing to other Indian tribes
for thousands of years the white
settlers were playing the same game of
conquest that Indian tribes had been
playing that all people everywhere
across the earth had been playing since
the dawn of human civilization it is
just absurd to treat the theft of land
by Europeans and Americans as a unique
evil for which we must repent and take
down our monuments in shame and weep and
cried it over and over and of it we
never stopped talking about what it
would have terrible evil we stole this
land we dope deserve to be here my god
wars of conquest have been waged had
been waged in this part of the world for
thousands of years before any white man
graced these shores wars of conquest of
taking over land and killing everybody
there enslaving their children and
taking their
scalps as souvenirs that's what was
happening in this country before anyone
with with you know lighter skin tones
ever showed up
slavery torture killings rape pillage
all of these were utterly common
features of Indian conflict anyone who
says otherwise is lying or stupid now
the white man came and jumped into that
fray he didn't invent the fray this is
how the world worked long before air
conditioning and Taco Bell and Twitter
accounts and we certainly can't say that
white people were unique in their
barbarism in the manner in which they
went about doing these things such
claims are rendered absurd by even a
cursory study of tribes like the
Comanche who were known to torture
babies to death and roasts people alive
or the Iroquois who committed a campaign
of extermination against the Huron tribe
over a century before the United States
was founded basically wiped them out
there's a book by SC Gwyn who's got I've
read a few of his books and they're all
really good Empire the summer moon about
the Comanche tribe and as he talks about
in his book you know these were and this
is not this book is not one long defense
of or apology for white settlers it's it
doesn't flinch from the evil done by
that group either but it gives a
balanced account and part of that
balanced account is to acknowledge that
Indian tribes in North America were
almost without exception brutal and
warlike and you could say well that was
that was the case across the world yes
you're exactly right you go back far
enough and everybody was that way
everywhere and that's to say nothing of
the Mesoamerican tribes like the Aztecs
and the Maya who engaged in human
sacrifice on a scale that is impossible
to fathom archaeologists are still
uncovering the endless towering racks of
skulls we
the dismembered heads of the butchered
victims were kept now it isn't difficult
to see maybe why the Spanish
conquistadors you know may have
developed a less than favorable
impression of the cultures they
encountered when they first landed in
Central America just imagine what you
would think if you witnessed an Indian
priest rip a still beating heart out of
a child while he was still alive I mean
what would you think if you saw that
this doesn't excuse the many acts of
brutality committed by the Spanish and
there were many such acts or any other
group of Europeans or Americans during
the 400-year Clash of Civilizations that
took place between you know the white
man and and and the Indian tribes but it
does underscore the need for historical
context it was a harsh and violent age
this is not now anytime you get is
someone says people say oh this is what
about isn't this is not what about ISM
you dunce this is about historical
context it's impossible to honestly and
fruitfully and constructively talk about
these things unless you understand them
in context it was a harsh and violent
age and the the world was being tamed
and settled by harsh and violent men
across the world empires were being
built by such men across the world in
this in in the new world - before it was
the new world before before Europeans
ever showed up there were empires and
they became how do you think they became
empires how do you think the Aztec
empire the Mayan Empire how do you think
any of these empires establish them but
through tickle fights pillow fights
through constructive dialogue through
debate that's what they did no they came
in two weaker tribes and killed
everybody in slave their children in
some cases gang raped the women that's
with a commune
cheese would do and took over now we I
think should be thankful that we have
the luxury to feel squeamish about it
now about the way the world worked about
the you know the law of conquest we
should be very thankful that we live in
a world at least in this part of the
world that well until the the anarchists
succeed in pulling us down into anarchy
again at least for now this is becoming
less the case but for now you know we we
live basically safe and comfortable
lives and as far as we're concerned most
of the lines have been drawn and we just
live here in relative luxury in fact not
just relative luxury but we live in
luxury that would have been unthinkable
unknown to the vast majority of the
human race that is that has ever existed
anywhere on earth so we you know a lot
has been said about the historical sins
of white Westerners we have been
confronting those sins for years now and
I'm sure that confrontation will
continue it's never allowed to stop but
if this confrontation occurs in a vacuum
without taking into consideration the
context of the time or the brutality of
the foes that the Westerners faced then
we'll be left with the impression that
white people today are the descendants
of history's greatest villains and that
nothing they did was justified let alone
admirable or worthy of celebration and
so yet turned out tear down all the
statues all the monuments they did
nothing good these were all the bad guys
and of course fostering this mistaken
impression is the point that's why we're
not allowed to have a discussion in
that's why somehow it's like provocative
for me to say the things that I'm saying
right now according to some people it's
not just provocative it's outrageously
offensive and racist all I'm saying is
verifiable historical truth should not
be provocative at all to point out that
300 years ago 500 years ago 600 years
thousand years ago was a brutal time
everybody was violent and lines were
drawn through killing each other you
know to most people in the world
hundreds of years ago the idea that you
should just respect someone's boundary
and the land that they claimed for
themselves even if they can't defend it
that idea to most people across the
world would have been absurd would have
been ridiculous it would have been
ridiculous too many Indian tribes the
idea that they should just ok well
that's your land but you can't really
we're stronger than you and we have
better technology and we want that land
for our hunting ground because you've
got a lot a lot of a lot of Buffalo in
your land and and and and and everything
and you've got resources we need but but
that's you you were there first and so
we'll just let you have it the I the the
very I notion of that would have been
laughably ridiculous because if they
couldn't defend the land you took it
your right to your land extended as far
as your ability to defend it that again
was the reality across the world for
thousands and thousands and thousands
and thousands of years and I think that
that context matters it doesn't matter
in assessing the objective morality of
the things that happen in the past
murder is murder and is always evil
stealing what is not yours is is
stealing and is always evil doesn't
matter if it happens in the year 2020 or
the year 1020 right but assessing the
moral culpability of the people who
commit these acts
that's where historical context really
matters so I have to say this again
because it's important and this is where
I'm always going to be misconstrued and
probably doesn't matter how much I
emphasize the point I'll still be
misconstrued because a lot of the
misconstrue
that goes on is willful but still I will
emphasize it again I'm not saying that
500 years ago or 300 years ago or
whatever that it was okay to take land
or kill people or pillage or do any of
that stuff what I'm saying is assessing
the moral culpability of the people who
engaged in those acts requires an
understanding of historical context
historical context is relevant to the
question of culpability not so much of
the objective moral truth of the matter
and that's it
okay we will move on to our headlines
but before we do I want to tell you
about paint your life you know having
nice artwork on your wall in your house
is this is something I'm only recently
discovering as I even though I'm 34 I'm
just now entering adulthood like so many
people in my generation and realizing
that you know if you have a home you got
to have artwork and paint your life you
couldn't ask for a better place to go to
get meaningful artwork and beautiful
artwork if you're looking for a way to
feel connected to the loved ones who you
can't be near you've got a tribe paint
your life come get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at a truly affordable price you
can choose from from a team of
world-class artists and you could work
with them through every detail to make
sure that everything is perfect they're
very responsive you know if you have
something you want to change or
adjustment you want to make they're
gonna be there they're gonna help you
it's a very user friendly platform and
it lets you order a custom made
hand-painted portrait in less than five
minutes quick and easy process and
extreme I was shocked by how affordable
it is as well given that these are real
artists making true artwork out of
pictures that already are so meaningful
to you at paint your life calm there's
no risk if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now is a limited
time offer get 20% off your painting
that's right 20% off and free shipping
to get this special offer text the word
matte to 64,000 that's matte to 64,000
text matte to 64,000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
okay number one it was a bloody weekend
five children were killed in our cities
over July 4th weekend all of them black
children nine people were shot in
Baltimore
69 people were shot in Chicago 16 of
those were killed 25 were shot in
Atlanta in you know one 24-hour period
on Sunday including an 8 year old girl
who was killed right near the spot where
Rashard Brooks was justifiably shot in
self-defense by police but there have
been protests going on there because of
that because of that justified shooting
of a violent criminal and in the midst
of all that chaos an 18 year I rather I
should say an 8 year old girl was killed
shot while she was in the car with her
parents the parents of the child spoke
out at a news conference watch this they
say that life matter you killed your own
get your own entire jail because of
burial they killed my baby because she
crossed the barrier the man you tell you
killed a child she knew not to nobody
even make a u-turn
sure you're not be killing your own you
killed eight yo ciao
he's gonna be none too now one of y'all
just wanted to get home to see y'all
good that's all she wanted to do still
want to get home so now you watch that
very gut-wrenching video of grieving
parents and you see in tragic detail the
total absurdity of the black lives
matter organization and the destructive
destructive movement that it has helped
to launch because BLM has nothing to say
about this child or for this child or on
this child's behalf there will be no
protests no riots not for her not for
any of the other four children killed
this weekend or the any of the the
dozens of other people killed in general
just this past weekend in our cities now
think about this nine unarmed black
people were shot and killed by police
all of last year nine only a couple of
those shootings were questionable most
of them were justified twenty-five
people were shot in Atlanta in 24 hours
now black lives matter tells us the
first thing the nine people that's a
horror worthy of rioting and protesting
the second thing the 25 is not nine
people in a year verse 25 in a day in
one city nine people across the country
in a year verse 25 in a day in one city
which is the the greater epidemic which
is the greater crisis which is affecting
communities more to reinforce the point
again compare nine unarmed black people
killed by cops in one year to nearly
twice as many black people killed in
Chicago in one weekend there are dozens
of ways to frame this nine unarmed black
people killed by police first five
children killed in one weekend now you
know the black lives matter if the name
of their organization was something like
police brutality is bad PBB instead of
BLM well then they'd have a little bit
more of an excuse to ignore the carnage
in our cities as they're doing but the
name of the organization is not police
brutality is bad the name of the
organization is black lives matter
they're supposed to be fighting for
defending attesting to the inherent
value of black life and and of all human
life that's what they would say I mean
they would claim that you know they're
not saying that all lives don't matter
there's you know they're just they're
focusing on this this problem of black
life being dehumanized and devalued in
our society that's what they would say
and if that's their mission and they say
that it is then there is nowhere that
this mission is more necessary than in
our cities addressing the violence
problem within the communities
themselves the person who shot into the
car where that eight-year-old girl was
sitting and killed her that is a person
who devalued her life discarded it
treated her life as nothing most of
these people that were killed this
weekend most of them would have been
killed for nothing for no real reason
either randomly or in robberies or in
gang disputes or drug-related violence
or for some other totally frivolous
reason yet you know yes oh yes there is
a real problem with life being devalued
in this country black life especially
but it's happening mostly within these
communities and BLM has nothing to say
because they are frauds they are total
absolute frauds number two
New York City's community education
Council District two had a zoom meeting
recently and you can actually watch the
entire video because it's public record
I don't know if you're gonna want to do
that because how long you can stomach
you know may vary it's really one of the
most nauseating spectacles of SJW
insanity that you'll ever see if you're
a little bit more optimistic maybe you
would say it's one of the most hilarious
spectacles I don't know I can't find the
humor in it as much because these
lunatics are teaching our children if
not for the
detail I'd be laughing too but the part
that scares me is that these are the
people teaching our children in schools
so let me just play one clip for you
just one example here's a count's
Councilwoman Rachel bro she taking
another council member to task for
committing the sin of allowing a black
child to sit on his lap now I'm not
joking here this is she's offended that
a white man and somehow that makes the
other guy illustrate to you that you
think excuse me you think I'm a social
justice and you think I'm being
patronizing and I'm getting pressure for
not being enough of an advocate I take
that to heart and that hurts me and I
don't want to make how to be a better
white person I would like to know before
this meeting adjourns on my lap was
hurtful oh dear God dear God do you see
why I'm such an advocate for homes going
these people have entirely lost their
minds we are watching as leftism
descends completely into insanity we are
witnessing a collective descent into
madness perhaps unlike anything the
world has ever seen before and it is
is at the at the at the tip of that
spear is the public school system so get
your kids the hell out of it right now
and you know parents will often because
I'm I'm railing against public school
system all the time
because the school system is an
abomination in pretty much every
conceivable way
and what I hear from parents a lot is
that they don't want to send their kids
to public school but they don't have any
other option because they can't
homeschool because they have both have
to work or it's a single-parent
household and they can't afford private
school what else are they supposed to do
and we're getting to the point where I
mean really any other option send your
kids into the woods to be raised by
coyotes okay anything would be better
really anything would be better than
sending them into the public school
system we are quickly approaching a
point where they're they're just it
would be difficult to come up with a
solid justification for wilfully
subjecting your kids to this number
three here's something check out this
viral photo of a maternity it's it's a
maternity photo shoot which is a thing I
guess where pregnant women get
professional photos done of themselves
because people have an insatiable
appetite to see pictures of themselves
and any opportunity is a good one it
seems so there's a twist though here
here's here's the pictures and she says
as you can see her pregnant belly is
covered in bees the Queen says the queen
is tethered to my belly inside of a cage
we just dumped the bees on me and they
naturally began to beard I was terrified
as I am allergic but it was worth it so
can I just say I had to mention this
because I'm as a beekeeper myself can I
just say that I do not endorse or
support the tribulation and
objectification of bees as you see in
that photo there I'm not concerned about
the you know the fact that
that how dangerous it is for people
that's that's not my point
bees should not be objectified in this
way or commodified or authorised in the
way that you see in this photo here
I'm absolutely outraged by that number
for a mob of vandals in Baltimore tore
down a statue of Columbus over the
weekend
once again no attempt was made to
prevent it no attempt is being made to
apprehend the criminal as far as far as
I could tell
here's what the mayor spokesman said he
said our officers in Baltimore City who
are some of the finest in the country
they are principally concerned with the
preservation of life that is sacrosanct
everything else Falls secondary to that
secondary to that including statues okay
so now somehow we have that so there's a
you have to make a choice now you can't
do both if it's not a crime that
directly threatens human life then you
can commit it is that is that really the
message you want to send from the
mayor's office well apparently it is now
I want you to compare that reaction to
this in California where a white man and
a white woman painted over a city
approved BLM mural it was right across
think it's right across the street those
in big big letters it said black lives
matter and two people came and painted
over it and here's what their Police
Department says reading now from NBC it
says the woman was caught on video by
onlookers as she painted over the words
black lives matter on the street in
front of the Contra Costa County
Courthouse while the man appeared to
film her on his phone authorities are
asking - but the public to identify the
couple so that they may be held
accountable for their actions according
to the police chief the press release
says the community spent a considerable
amount of time putting the mural
together only to have it painted over in
a hateful and senseless manner the city
of Martinez values tolerance and the
damage to the mural was divisive and
hurtful so you just see and of course
that you know many leftists and the
media they're passing around the video
of these two people painting over the
mural and saying how horrible it is and
they finally found a a form of vandalism
that they disapprove of and it's
painting over a mural on the street
you know these statues that are being
torn down you want to talk about a lot
of time being spent is a consider a lot
of time putting the mural together it's
just it's just letters on the street
okay I could have done that in 15
minutes
that Columbus statue that was torn down
or something these other statues
especially that are much older do you
know how much time they took to make and
how much pride these communities have
taken in them for decades only to have
this band of criminals tear it down
because they personally don't like it
yeah but that's okay but painting over a
mural now there now there is vandalism
that is just totally unacceptable
apparently let's move on to our daily
cancelation for our daily cancelation
I'm gonna be canceling not just these
two girls but but them and anyone like
them watch this I'm ashamed to be an
American and I won't forget being slave
to tide and built this place for free so
I proudly lived up all the folks who are
still oppressed today because there
ain't no doubt this ain't our land Trump
in the USA ouch
another cringe challenge there that's a
tough one to get through that's real
that's difficult and the worst part is
that they had to sit down and rehearse
this and plan it and probably write it
and practice it get a little bit of
choreography in there to and from the
sound of it and the look of it it seems
like they're at the pool you can hear
the water in the background they seem to
be wearing bathing suits so they're
relaxing at the pool and suddenly they
decide to spend their time writing a
song about how much they hate living in
the country where they have the luxury
to hang out at the pool singing songs
about how much they hate their country
just imagine having a mind that works
that way well you're sitting there it's
July 4th weekend you're in the Sun
you're having a drink maybe drink some
lemonade
relaxing and you turn to your friend and
say you know
I really hate it here it's just imagine
being such a miserable person but as I
say I'm not just canceling them I'm
canceling anyone like them like for
example these people as well so a cute
little rhyme they're not quite as
inventive or elaborate as the as the
girls singing the other song but as you
see these are these are all well-dressed
well-fed privileged brats chanting about
the inherent evils of the country that
allows them to burn its flag in the
middle of street without consequence now
it should go without saying that if they
tried that stunt in many other countries
across the globe they'd all be dead or
in shackles before they got to five six
seven eight now I mean if you look in
India for example you can be imprisoned
for wearing clothing with the Indian
flag on it much less burning the flag in
the middle of the street
in Malaysia nine Australians were sent
to jail for three days for wearing
Speedos decorated with the Malaysian
flag the slightest disrespect of the
flag in Saudi Arabia is will be met with
extremely severe punishment and that
includes flying the flag at half-mast
even that is considered to be flag
desecration and punishable by prison
time so or worse you know this is Saudi
Arabia we're talking about but of course
these protesters don't have to worry
about that because they live here where
they have in fact not just freedom but
much more freedom than they should have
they have freedom for example to burn
buildings and destroy public property
that's freedom they should not have by
any reasonable you know a point of view
but they do but the fact that they live
here that's the interesting part and
this is why all of these people are
cancelled and I know I'm obviously not
the first person to
make this point I'm probably not even
the millionth person to make this point
but it's a good point and one that has
yet to be answered and so I'm going to
make it again and the point is this if
you believe that America is inherently
evil systemic ly racist and in fact that
there is no progress not even the
election of a black president that could
even slightly change that fact and if
you further believe that this country
was built on stolen land and that we
have no right to be here that there's
almost nothing praiseworthy or good and
certainly nothing uniquely good about
America or its history then the obvious
question remains why the hell are you
here why don't you leave there are a
hundred and ninety five countries in the
world we're just one of them that leaves
you 194 other countries you could go to
2/3 of those countries are in largely
non-white non-western areas why don't
you move to one of them seriously why
not this is not a rhetorical question I
really want to know the answer now the
first and most obvious and really only
available rebuttal or answer to this
question is that they stay here despite
feeling this way about America because
they want to fight for change and
progress and that's what it's all about
that's why they're not going to leave
but that excuse is a total non-starter
because the things they hate about
America are all things that cannot be
changed if they are indeed true and even
the things that seem like they should be
able to be changed if they were true
apparently can't be if this country was
built on stolen land and we have no
right to be here then there is no social
progress that will ever change that fact
it would be like buying a car that you
know is stolen and rather than giving it
back to the owner you decide that you're
gonna you know drive it around but
you're gonna keep it clean and you're
gonna help you know you're gonna give
old people rides to the supermarket
every Wednesday or something like that
you're gonna use your car for good okay
you can do all you want like that but
that's not going to
change the fact that it isn't your car
and you shouldn't have it and by driving
it you are participating in and
profiting off of its theft the supposed
systemic racism in our country would
seem like something that could be fixed
if it existed which it doesn't but if it
did you'd think okay well there's
something at least that we can fix but
as I said the left has made it clear
that nothing can really change that by
they're telling the election of a black
president didn't even improve the the
problem of systemic race it's not just
that that we still have a problem it
said it's it's it's not even better
after that it's still as much of an
issue now as it ever was before
according to them which means it would
seem that it can never be changed
America is sick to its core according to
them so given all of this I mean if you
believe that these are all Givens I
don't but if you do the only ethical
choice is to donate your assets to a
Indian Reservation and move to a country
in Africa or Asia or even Central or
South America and and you know that that
would seem like the only ethical option
yet nobody is doing this it's not just
that only a few of the protesters are
doing it or that not enough or doing it
none of them are none the option isn't
even being discussed it's it's not it's
not even brought up all of these people
sitting around burning the flag
lamenting our existence on this stolen
land none of them none of them ever stop
and say hey you know maybe we should
just leave it would be like if I claimed
that a local store sells stolen
merchandise and that its management is
comprised of murderous racists who use
the profits from their stores to
subjugate and kill minorities and yet I
still went there every day to shop
walking through the aisles shouting my
laments own oh woe is me the store is
terrible is it awful stores so the store
should not be hey by the way how much is
this fedora forty five dollars that's
not too bad okay am i doing anyway was I
saying oh yeah so who the store is
terrible oh my god if you caught me
acting that way there would only be two
possible explanations
number one I don't really believe any of
the claims I'm making about the store or
two I am willfully complicit in the evil
done by the store and its ownership and
therefore not any better than them now
in the case of these protesters and the
others who profess their hatred for
America while choosing to remain here
I think the first explanation is
probably closest to the truth they don't
really believe this bullcrap that
they're spewing they don't really
believe it it's a game it's just
something to do they're bored they're
looking for a boogey man to fight
against and so they're out there acting
like they're Freedom Fighters struggling
against an enemy that doesn't exist
acting like they're being oppressed
meanwhile they're able to do literally
whatever the hell they wants yet you're
so oppressed that you can go and burn
down a freakin building and steal all
the merchandise and nobody will arrest
you for it
that's how oppressed you are now as I
said it's not just that you're more free
than anybody else in the kind the world
you you're way more free than you should
be because it's because that's a freedom
nobody should have yet if you're on the
left and you're a quote-unquote
protestor you have that freedom I mean
you you you belong to the most free
group of people that maybe has ever
lived so no I just don't I don't believe
that they believe what they're saying I
don't because if
really did now maybe on some level you
know on some surface level consciously
they've they've been able to fool
themselves but if they really really
believed it then that's what they would
do there is there would be no excuse no
justification for not donating your
assets to an Indian tribe and leaving
lead by example right America was never
great America's was never great it's not
great now it can never be great if all
of these claims about it are true so go
to a different cut go to a country that
even if there are no great countries
that there's got to be a country better
than this one right this is a racist
dystopia built on the back of slaves and
and through the blood of genocide you
would say right so I mean there's
there's got to be many better options
but no you stay here because again
you're all frauds all of you and on that
cheerful note we will end it for the day
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there